I think I know why you're happy tonight
save it every for this I really know
this time because it came out today just
today Amazon is buying Whole Foods you
will be getting kale delivered right to
your door
it's Liberal Christmas everyone liberal
now the other reason you're probably
happy is this Donald Trump have you been
following what this guy's up to
[Music]
for months he has been absolutely
obsessed with harassing every single law
enforcement official in the federal
government to tell everybody I'm not
under personal investigation not
personal investigation tell everybody
well that weaves under personal advice
that's the big sorry that happened this
rate the charge is obstructed of justice
and it was the typical pattern we've
seen with the news The Washington Post
acting on leaks broke this story around
5:00 p.m. a few days ago Fox News spent
all night trying to debunk it and then
Trump himself confirms it during his
four a.m. poop tweet you know then the
other news outlets rolled tried to
confirm this but why at 3:55 a.m. Trump
tweeted now they go for obstruction of
justice nice this is like Watergate if
deep throat was Nixon
I usually usually these federal
investigations go slowly not this one
special prosecutor Robert Miller has
already hired 13 lawyers with plans to
hire a lot more he is so far up trumps
ad he had to ask Putin to scoot over
and Muller and his team I've already
found a clue that Trump fired Kohli to
stop the Russia investigation it's the
time Trump went on TV and said I fired
call me to stop this Russian
investigation that's the clue boy he's a
master criminal district so you know
panic is the word that they're using
about what's going on at the White House
everybody is lawyering up
Trump's lawyer hired a lawyer I'm not
making that up apparently the only
person who has no use for lawyers is
Donald Trump
they say all he does all day he watches
TV stewing about this he was so upset
about all this this week he called in
the entire cabinet for an emergency
Flattery meeting oMG did you see this
did you see did you see what went on at
this cabinet meeting up I did and I
immediately called an emergency meeting
at my liquor cabinet Oh
[Applause]
I can't believe this is really happening
Trump started things off by blowing
himself he said never has there been a
president who's done more things than I
have then they all took turns around the
table verbally fellating the Dear Leader
Reince Priebus said we thank you for the
opportunity and the blessing you've
given us to serve your agenda this is
how Scientologists talk about l ron
Hubbard please these are cabinet members
these people used to have dignity they
were Republicans but they had dignity
and now they're going around the table
pardon me sir if I avert my gaze as you
shine with the power of a million Suns
your enormous brain casts a great shadow
I am but a mushroom who grows in its
change Rex Tillerson said I don't want
to say your dick is big mr. president
but I'm standing on it
and then the next decade Trump turned 71
so if you're wondering if this is the
year he settles down now you're thinking
of a golden retriever turning 3 so yeah
it turns 70 why that a big birthday
celebration at the White House on
Wednesday they brought out a cake from
closed his eyes made a wish blow out the
candles and a funke's dress fall off
I get that Trump badly come on Melania
moved into the White House this week
none into trumps room in the trophy room
like hey speaking of trophies there was
a moment of healing this week after that
horrible mass shooting we had that
wounded a Republican congressman okay
that was a reform they're going to have
they went ahead with the game when the
Republicans played the Democrats and the
Democrats won the game but after the
game after the game they did a nice
thing even though they won they took the
trophy and they handed it to the
Republicans just like they did with the
last election all right